Richard lengerman when did you very and
the very first time you get interested
in Sinclair Lewis remember well I think
it's when I read Main Street and I come
from a small town in Indiana and so I
that kind of Liberty was a liberating
experience because it was about like my
own hometown what was Main Street when
did it when was it published Main Street
came out in 1920 was the sensation and
it was a novel about a village called
gopher Prairie in the state of Minnesota
what were you from an idiom I'm from
Crawfordsville Indiana which is a much
larger town but still it had some of the
aspects of a small town the provincial
ISM and the conformity when dead
Sinclair Lewis live he was born 1885 and
died 1951 how many times was he married
and he was married twice to one once to
a New York woman named Grace and second
time to a famous columnist named Dorothy
Thompson how many children did he have
he had two two boys one by his first
wife died in World War two and the
second one became an actor and he died
young of a form of cancer how many books
did he write
he wrote 22 novels he was very prolific
did he make a lot of money and he was
exceedingly successful writer and the
funnies are the bestseller and even in
this lowest period in the 30s he would
sell 50,000 copies so he made a good
living and if you were to define him as
an individual what would you say I would
say he was a man with a fierce sense of
injustice
and a sense of of what was wrong with
America and a desire to change it to
reform it he was also he could be a rude
man he was had he is very quick-witted
he had little patience with cliches and
and also he liked to at least in the as
earlier years he liked to do
monologues at parties so he would be
constantly doing a monologue and an
impression if somebody would often be a
character in his next novel he was witty
and and he was also truculent and he was
a bundle of paradoxes where did he live
in his life oh he was he had no fixed
address you might say that's
exaggerating but he he moved around a
lot
from boyhood and then New York for a
while when he worked but he quit his job
became a full-time writer and so he
moved around he lived in the Twin Cities
and then he he lived in Washington to
write Main Street and he came back to
Washington after Main Street was a big
success he went to Europe and he went
all over Europe and he lived in
Minnesota again and he lived in
Massachusetts he never really settled
down Sauk center Minnesota where is it
oh that's in the southwest part of the
state it's in a sort of the flat part of
the state it's a wheat country there
used to be a wheat country I think they
put different crops in now but it was a
typical Minnesota town with the Swedish
farmers and the German farmers and the
and the Yankees who ran the town how
long did you live there and he he lived
there really just his first 17 years and
then he he went away to prep school to
prepare for college and at Oberlin prep
and then he went to Yale
then after Yale he he never well he
returned briefly then he started
wandering and he went off on your
opening pages of the pictures here his
father dr. EJ Lewis is at the top what
was he like and what did he do well he
was a typical country doctor he was a
very meticulous man and a very punctual
man the people said they could set their
watches by him every day when he walked
to the office at the same time and and
he was a rather Stern man but I think he
and he could never quite make make out
what what Harry that was what Sinclair
Lewis's boyhood name was his full name
was Harry Sinclair Lewis and he kept
telling Harry why can't you be a normal
boy like all every other boy and but
Harry was different and he couldn't but
I think he was like on the whole a good
father his mother and his his birth
mother died when he was six I think that
was a kind of a traumatic event in his
life and that he didn't remember her
very well and and but I think that was a
loss of tenderness and maternal
affection and it was a shock to him and
he became withdrawn afterwards but his
father who was known as dr. EJ married
another woman Isabel Warner and and she
was a good woman and she lavished her
maternal instincts on Harry his he had
two older brothers but they were much
older and they were one was seven years
and one was 15 years older and so she
concentrated on him and and I think drew
him out of his shell and she was in many
ways a good woman and she she did a lot
for the town you know all these public
services and so and you see some of her
in the female character the heroine of
Main Street Carol Kennecott
who tries similar projects what was the
impact of Main Street and what was it
about well it was a sensation it was
compared to Uncle Tom's Cabin in the way
it it provoked a nationwide controversy
it was there's a little slower and
building but it you know started in New
York and spread West because there
wasn't the media that there is today but
it did build up and and it had the you
know people discussing was a was this a
true picture of America I mean were
because those claims in the forward this
stands for America this Main Street runs
right through all America and this town
of Grover go for Prairie sets the
standards for all America and so people
just discussed you know are we
provincial and are we hostile to culture
and are we conformist and and and then a
lot of people who read it were
small-town people who had moved to the
cities and and they read it and they
wanted to be it soon became a term a
Main Street or if you're a Main Street
are you or kind of a hick a provincial
and so they wanted to read it so they
wouldn't be a Main Street and but it did
this was at a time in America of
transition after World War one and
America was assuming a new role because
it had come through the war and helped
help win the World War one and and that
it was suddenly a mores on the world
stage than it ever was before and it was
very strong economically while Europe
was devastated and so people abroad to
or interested
and what was America like and so Lewis's
book starting with Main Street were much
read abroad and but it did cause a great
furor and debate in the country and
there was a healthy debate and some I
mean people were seriously discussing
you know should we educate ourselves
more and travel more and and and then
the younger generation who were
rebelling against the old ways took
gopher Prairie as a symbol of what they
were rebelling against the old the old
America the old time America was gopher
Prairie Sauk center his hometown yeah
pretty much so he he would always say it
was a composite of small towns and he
did before he wrote it he was a great
researcher he traveled over all the way
west driving in a car with his wife
first wife Grace and and visiting small
towns and and but I think it was a Sauk
center that was basically the same and
that was imprinted on his consciousness
Sauk center and he had his visualized
this novel when he had come home from
college from Yale in his sophomore year
and he was sitting around and as often
happens in a small town you're bored and
you to feel hemmed in and thwarted and
and and he invented this idea of the
village virus something that gets into
you and then dulls your mind and makes
you stop thinking and go to seed you
know so he so he thought he'd write a
novel about this and so that was back in
nineteen three I believe and he kept it
in his mind all those years and so
certainly Sauk center was the irritants
that that yielded this Perl if you will
you say he was 35 in 1921 this book
was published yeah and he wrote it right
down town here near the Mayflower Hotel
why was he here well he he had been
wandering and he had gone they had gone
out to the Twin Cities and lives and st.
Paul and Minneapolis and he and his wife
and and they they finally got sort of
bored and then they are there Lisa's ran
out and they they were having a little
trouble with fitting in socially with
the people there and then he went to
Mankato a small town in southern
Minnesota and and that became the model
for the town that Carol comes from and
the character in the book yeah Carol
Kennecott yeah and she comes from there
and that's sort of her ideal town it's a
very pleasant New England style town and
so but their lease ran out and then they
came east in the way or we're gypsies
they said where we gonna live and they
thought New York that in New York was
too expensive and they thought
Washington had a more relaxed low-key
atmosphere if you can believe it that
was the Washington of those days you
know it was a quiet southern town on the
back of your book Studs Terkel the
chicago one has a note he says as a
sequel to his Magisterial biography of
theodore dreiser richard lengerman has
put forth at long last the definitive
life of Sinclair Lewis the other genius
curmudgeon of our literature it's a
touch of fate I think that lingman out
of the Midwest provincial Crawfordsville
is just the boy to celebrate the Scourge
--is of our sacrosanct who came from
equally endowed American towns Terre
Haute and Sauk center when did you write
the book on Theodore Dreiser well that
came out and it came out in two volumes
nineteen
76 and 19 I'm sorry 1986 in 1990 when
did Theodore Dreiser live and write and
he was he was born in 1871 and he died
in 1945 there's that moment in your book
where a Dreiser
and Lewis have a falling out over what
yeah well they they didn't know each
other well but Lewis oiz prays dreicer
is a great pioneer a great Pathfinder he
was an older rider too Louis and then
but they dreicer have written a book
about Russia and it visited during the
20th anniversary of the revolution or
the tenth anniversary sorry
and then Dorothy Thompson whom Lewis was
just falling in love with this is in
1928 she had gone there she was a
foreign correspondent and then she later
wrote a book and then this New York
columnist F P Adams noticed similarities
in their two books and and he accused he
made it clear that he thought dreicer
had lifted passages from Dorothy's book
and Lewis was infuriated and and he
dragged Dorothy up to his lawyer and
said we're going to sue dries fitter and
then dry sphere oh I got very messy and
dry sir was saying that he had implying
he had been in a minute with Dorothy
well she was she was really engaged to
Lewis at this time and that she had
given him his her notes for him to use
and anyway they didn't sue and which was
probably fortunate but then had a
literary dinner for a Russian writer
they came in and Lewis came in he was
a bit four sheets to the wind and he he
got up and others people were expressing
their respects for Dreiser and he said I
will not give my respects to a man who
stole 3,000 words from my wife's book
and then Louis asked I sir
said after the dinner they met and he
said take that back Louis boy said say
that again Louis and Louis said it again
and he said okay I'm gonna slap you and
he slapped him now are you gonna
apologize and said nope I'm not gonna
take it back hit me again
so lo dreicer slapped him again and then
a friend of his trousers pinyon Lewis
and dreicer walked away so this was a a
literary fight between two literary
gents and it was a headline news all
over the country by the way you can't go
but a couple pages without you writing
something about his drinking yeah either
he was drunk on occasion or he was in a
period of sobriety how much alcohol did
he consumed in his life I don't mean by
the gallon but I mean explain that well
I say he was an alcoholic he it got very
bad where he was he would go on binges
wherever he would go drinking for weeks
on end and sometimes he'd go on the
wagon but it broke up the marriage with
his first wife
they separated because he said she's a
you're always lecturing me and you're
always ordering me around and because of
my drinking and and so I can't stand it
you're making me drink more and so he
split up with her and then and then the
second wife the same things the drinking
and the they
he would fight I don't think he would
get violent but his his tongue was very
violent and they would have these awful
quarrels those were symptoms of it and
he would go on binges as I said and and
finally reached the point where doctors
told him you're gonna die if you keep
drinking like that and that was in the
about 1938 so he did quit for a while he
was married to his first wife Grace for
how many years that was about ten years
and their only son's name was he was
named Welles after HG Wells did he no HT
Welles yes he was
Welles HG Wells was one of the big
influences on his early writing career
and he finally did meet him in the
twenties and and they became rather
friendly how long was he married to
Dorothy Thompson and he married her and
29 and they divorced in 40 about 11
years they had one son Michael yes
Michael he said he died in alcoholic
well no he he did have trouble with
drinking and he it was sad because he
felt it was his heredity and and he told
his daughter that having two famous
parents and had really suppressed his
sense of himself a sense of self-worth
and and he would say he would read about
his father say oh I'll do just like my
father I can do anything I want I can
drink all I want and it was sad and and
but he I think he curbed it and he
actually died of a Hodgkin's lymphoma
and so I don't think he died of the
drink but he died in his early fifties
early the rest of what stud Circle
Terkel said about you as no New Yorker
could possibly have written these books
layman's biography of Lewis as well as
the other theodore dreiser has that
unique tribute the feeling tone you said
you're from Crawfordsville Indiana
three-hour dry sir was from Terre Haute
another figure in the book is Eugene
Debs the moment in Terre Haute what was
Debs
relationship to Sinclair Lewis well he
was one of Lewis's idols and when Lewis
first moved to Greenwich Village in
around 1910 he became a member of the
Socialist Party and he was quite a
radical young men and and I believe he
met dabs air and because and but he
admired him greatly and and he gradually
build him up as a kind of a Christ
figure in his mind which Deb's was kind
of to the labor movement and how many
times the Deb's run for president Oh
Alice he started in Oh for I believe in
the he ran through last time was twenty
eight until five or six times yeah yeah
and he I guess in the 1912 he got about
a million votes and he was quite a
powerful speaker and then a powerful
figure in American politics and for the
for the working people and Lewis admired
him a lot and then Deb's went to prison
because he opposed World War one and
made a speech and they were very strong
laws against sedition and and he got out
and and list wanted to write a novel
about labor and he thought he would
model the character on Deb's and and
Deb's had just got out of prison he was
and he was oppressed by all the battles
going on within the labor movement and
the rise of the Communist Party and and
the fault of the Socialist Party was
splitting up and anyway Louis went out
to Chicago where Deb's was staying at a
sanitarium there to recoup his health
and and
and he talked to him and and he
endeavors was willing to cooperate and
you know he said he would change him so
it wasn't really like Deb's but he would
base it on his life and but he he just
couldn't McKidd go he said
and then he met some doctors out there
and he's decided to do a novel about a
doctor Aerosmith had said but he
continued to dream of this novel about
Debs all through the rest of his writing
career but you're speaking about Arif
Smith one of the 22 novels the Pulitzer
Prize he turned it down for that novel
why well he you could there was some
sense of revenge in it perhaps but I
think it was a high-minded sense in that
Main Street was chosen by the judges for
the 1920 future and but then the
trustees of the prize have the final say
they overruled and gave it to trustees
of Columbia Columbia right yeah who
administer the Pulitzer trust and and
they overturned it and awarded it to
Edith Wharton's the age of innocence so
Lewis felt that that they was these oh
the old guard s of literature the
conservatives of literature and who
thought that he was too critical of
America and the terms of the prize said
something about that this should
represent the highest aspects of the
American character or some words that
imply that it should be uncritical look
at America and and he thought this would
further thort writers that they would
that this prize would become so central
that it would set standards for American
literature and so and Aerosmith won the
award he turned it down and he wrote a
long letter giving his reasons and but
mainly it was a protest against this he
thought the prize was notifying and
and it it set to conservative standards
for American Novel writing and American
novelist should be free and and I
shouldn't be herded into a certain kind
of writing and for right or wrong and
but I think was a principled stand he
took a lot of people thought he was a
public publicity huh what was Sinclair
Lewis's relationship to the Nation
magazine well he was the regular
contributor in the twenties and he was a
friend of the editor Oswald Garrison
Villard and I think the politics of the
nation then dovetails very comfortably
with Lewis's they supported the nation
supportive senator and the father who
ran on the Progressive Party ticket in
24 against Coolidge and and Louis wrote
some articles for them doing mock
interviews with the Main Street people
and asking them who they supported and
and he'd ask Carol Kennecott and her
husband doctor will Kennecott and and
some of the other characters and also
Babbitt he asked Babbitt and anyway he
he because he was sort of a conservative
radical I guess you'd say or he was a
radical in the in a good suit he always
clung to a vision of socialism but he
didn't have anything a clear program but
he he certainly based his criticisms of
America on that and the nation was very
sympathetic the Lord was very
sympathetic to him
and he liked Villard what's your
relationship to the Nation magazine well
my relationship is that I've worked
there about 20 years and
and I was executive editor there and now
I'm a senior editor there and so I've
had a very close relationship and and I
appreciate the tradition in fact I
wasn't quite aware of it Lewis had
written that much or that there was this
correspondence between him and the Lord
and Villard wanted him to cover the the
party conventions and then Lewis changed
said he would then he changed his mind
and Villard had already advertised that
Lewis would be writing and then so that
got a lot of subscriptions and so he was
he was really stuck there he thought
he'd have to refund the money but then
Lewis agreed to write these other
interviews for it which you told us
early in this that year from
Crawfordsville Indiana yeah he was from
Sauk center Minnesota yeah he worked for
the Nation magazine you work for the
Nation magazine yeah
and Theodore Dreiser was your first it
was a your first book now I wrote a
couple of others but on World War 2 the
home front during World War two and one
called small-town America and then of
course we talked about Eugene Debs how
much of your own life is what I'm
getting at is in Sinclair Lewis's life
well I think it was again it was when we
were talking about when I first read him
and that I I think it was actually when
I was away at college and and going I
went east to college and identified with
him who went east to college and and
coming from a small town in the Midwest
you have a certain inferiority feeling
even though I I didn't go to Yale I went
to Haverford College which was a small
college but still it seems all these
Eastern prep school graduates there and
or seemed somehow it to my naive I to be
suave ER and more cultured and but
anyway the I think that sense of
identity and it gave me
coming from a small town if that it had
made an impression on me and so my
senior year I wrote a paper on Sinclair
Lewis and and sort of biographical study
of him never and little did I know that
I would become involved or deeply with
him but I always liked him it always
liked his satire and his Babbitt I could
think of Babbitt's in my hometown that I
knew and so I guess he was just awakened
me to aspects of America and and
confirmed some of my own experiences as
a boy Haverford is located where in
Philadelphia now he went to Overland for
a while what happened to him and the
Ohio school Oberlin well he went there
at Overland at that time was a very
religious place and there was there
trying to you know turn out missionaries
and he went there for a prep school
course so that he could pass the Yale
exams but he became very religious there
and he he was going to become a
missionary and he gave you know he made
a whatever he called a decision for
Christ and and they said I'm going to go
out and become a missionary and he
underlines this and his this diary he
kept and so he was caught up in religion
and he was and which is kind of ironic
for the mataron Elmer Gantry but not
really because he later became
disillusioned and he swung the opposite
way and but overland this sense of faith
and of Christianity this inspired him
and this disillusioned him and that had
an impact on his life and so when he
wrote about a small Midwestern college
they were based on Oberlin and when he
wrote against religion I think he was
writing out of a disillusionment his own
disillusionment in his loss of faith
that in a way that he had had and that
he said to Upton Sinclair once that our
religion draws in idealistic young men
and their what a waste when they could
be out working to improve the world and
he didn't think religion organized
religion was doing anything to help the
world and that's he became a socialist
in the agnostic or atheist and so that
experience and it was kind of comical he
was just so religious and he was he was
going to he would he would go teach a
Sunday School class and they would go in
one of these old railroad hand cars you
know what you pumped up and down and
that happens in Elmer Gantry too and
they go to this little village he and
the other students and they would teach
Sunday School and and he would he when
his father told him one of the local
boys and Sauk center was taking up
cigarettes and drinking whiskey and he
said well send him out to me I'll take
care of you know to set him straight so
he became quite fanatic for a while but
then he quickly cooled and then Yale he
became a socialist so that's the story
of his Oberlin career but he made much
use of Overland's as a setting for the
small colleges and several of his novels
the book Babbitt when was that written
and what was it about
well that was written after Main Street
in the 1921 he had wanted it came from
basically two ideas I think there's two
obsessions one was with a kind of
he wanted a hero who was a Salesman and
who was selling just for the sake of
selling and making people buy things
that they might not want to buy and he
wanted to write a book set in a
medium-sized city population 200,000 to
500,000 he said this this place hasn't
been written about in American
literature not really a place like
Seattle or Minneapolis or Hartford or
places like that and so his first
conception that he told his publisher
was that that babbitt is all of us at
48:46 a man who's who's wondering is is
is just buying a new car and buying a
better house enough I mean isn't there
something more in life some romance or
or something else you know I guess we'd
say he's a man in a midlife crisis and
but he and I think he wanted to satirize
the businessman so he he started
planning it and he started he went out
to the Midwest he was on a kind of a
speaking tour but he would do research
for his book he would talk to people
talk to businessmen and listen to their
and note down the way they talked and
then he would read the society pages and
he would read trade magazines and and he
would go visit real estate officers and
bad what's a real estate man and so
that's that started the research and
then he he he went through
well he was developing a system and for
writing novels and he so he after he did
the research he filled this notebook
full of stuff and then he'd add
biographies of all the characters and he
he'd have to get the names for the
characters and the name was very
important to him his publisher Alfred
Harcourt said you write to her name and
he said enough character doesn't come
alive till I know the name and and so
with babbity originally called pub free
that wasn't right it was just too
English into a feet and he thought of
Fitch and he thought of some other names
and he wanted a common name sort of but
not as common as Smith or Jones but so
finally Babbitt came out and they're
different series for the origin of it
but anyway babbit George ff4 follansby
Babbitt and that seemed to be the the
right name and it was and so and he went
on down the list all these other
characters in there he was great on
names like T Chumlee Frank who was the
advertising man poor Chum Frink or opal
Emerson Mudge who was the new thought
guru and Vergil gunch who was the very
conservative guy who catches Babbitt out
when he's dallying with this beautiful
widow named tennis Judique and so on but
hitting write he drop all the names of
the characters he'd read biographies of
them and and then when he was in England
he at the Cornwall and the hotel he was
preparing it and talking with his wife
about it and and he made maps he drew up
maps of seventeen maps of the well this
the state of in which Babbitt is that's
what I must state in which matter
which Zenith davits hometown is located
and he do drew maps of Zenith and then
he drew maps of Babbitt's neighborhood
which that one is and then he drew maps
of Babbitt's office and Babbitt's house
both floors and every room in the house
and they were incredibly detailed and
the Cincinnati plays a part in this
doesn't it yes he I think he started out
in Cincinnati that was his base for his
research and he stated and I believe the
Athletic Club there queen Queen City
Club I mean was called and and he talked
a lot of people there and he and there's
some society notes that he lifted and
put in to Babbitt this he parodied the
society reporter Main Street in 1920
babbitt in 1922 what was the political
impact of babbitt any well it at first
it was the people it was satirizing such
as the the real estate people and the
also the what we call the service club
members of the Rotary Club and the
Kiwanis Club they sort of took it in
stride is saying oh yeah we all know
babbitt's in our profession but then I
don't know it seemed that gradually they
became aware of that it was kind of a
subversive book it was anti business and
this was you know during the 20s which
was a conservative time and and so it
was began attacking it and if defending
Babbitt and they saying Babbitt it's not
a bad guy he's a good guy he's and he
he's the kind of American we approve up
and and of course Lewis was always
ambivalent he he always said I love
Babbitt you know I think ballets a great
guy but he just you know he should read
mourned and
understand more and then pay more
attention to politics and don't believe
the canned opinions he gets to the
newspaper and things like that so but it
didn't there was sort of a backlash
against babbit but Adelaide when it was
a sensation when it came out on page yet
212 you have a couple of quotes here
from Gracie to friend Stella wood and
you quote the letters from Gracie to
Stella would all through the book who is
Stella would well she was a pioneering
teacher that they met in st. Paul and
she started kindergarten there and and
she was worked with very young children
and and grace had become quite impressed
with her and and learned from her about
taking care of children the reason I
mentioned because I want to read a
little bit what you write relating to
what you just said about babbit Gracie
Express house view to Stella would have
meaning Sinclair Lewis who had raised
the popular objection quote this is what
Gracie wrote how is not a medicine man
he has no remedies to offer who would
take them if he did and you write he
believed that Americans would get more
out of life quote if we would only try
to see and see his in big letters so he
tries to force our eyes open unquote she
said and then awareness was Lewis's
program you right it's true I think yeah
Gracie was was very insightful and I
think she sort of expressed his views
but that could because he always said I
mean I I could backtrack a little and
say that when he first wrote a draft of
Main Street he had all kinds of
suggestions for what to do about small
towns that were you know ugly and badly
designed like go for Prairie but he took
them out of the book because he a person
who had rented another novelist James
branch cabell said well it distracts
from the story and his notes for Babbitt
you can see his suggestions
Babbitt's you know if they would just do
this and that but he felt that that
didn't have a place and it's not all he
wasn't there to offer programs and but
it was very important to him I think
this idea of awareness and I'm glad you
mentioned it because he felt that people
who go for Prairie we're sort of
mentally dead and that they just live
life so habit and they and they thought
in cliches and and he thought the same
thing about it that Babbitt went through
these ritualized social encounters with
the with the Roughnecks the table at at
the Athletic Club and and and he would
go out and sort of tell lies to sell
houses and and he was in a hole which
realized life and but he wasn't thinking
for himself
Main Street 1920 babbitt 1922 based at
Main Street in Sauk center Minnesota
called Grover gopher gopher Prairie the
town of Zenith for Babbitt that's
Cincinnati
pretty much Martin Aerosmith or
Aerosmith the book was centered in what
location well it was it was said of this
some of it anyway the early parts were
said in this mythical state of Winamac
where he Martin grows up and he studies
he gets his medical md degree at the
university of winning back the state
university and that's kind of where in
the united states and that's well he
said the northern border was Michigan
and
the Western Illinois the southern was
Indiana and the eastern was Ohio so it's
sort of in Lake Michigan and that was
1925 and then in 1927 Elmer Gantry and
that was located where well that was
also started out in the a lot of it was
in the state of Winamac yeah much of it
and then a gantry ends up in Zenith and
well he doesn't end up there he goes
through Zenith for a while then he's
called in New York and Elmer Gantry was
what was what he do well he was hover
gantry was he went out became a I went
to Divinity School became a minister and
then but he was kind of bored with that
and and he becomes he gets in trouble
first with drinking and wenching shall
we say and so he loses his his pulpit
and but then he joins up with this
evangelists woman evangelist named
Sharon Falconer and so he becomes an
evangelist a traveling evangelist and
you know in those days they had these
the tent show evangelists and the
and they had they literally spread the
sawdust on the on the ground and you'd
to and they'd call for you to decide for
Christ and you march up the sawdust
trail and and so anyway he's very
successful but then her career is
destroyed she dies in a fire so he goes
on and becoming an evangelist but
eventually returns to the organized
Church and rises in that and becomes a
respectable figure but is more dangerous
in the way India who is William the
Reverend William is its teacher surgery
yeah he was he was a minister in Kansas
City and he had met Louis and in Terre
Haute when Lewis was there visiting Debs
and they had talked to standard
criticized him for the minister he
created in Babbitt called dr. John
Jennison Drew and but Lewis had taken
some of dr. Drew's ideas for pepping up
the church from stitchers ideas which
were you know how to increase the
collection plate and how to make the
church pay he said and you know it's
just ways to raise money and they just
run the church more like a business you
quote did your daughter Betty and she's
still alive
no his I got that from his grandson I
believe yeah yes did you still lie I
don't know but his grads though did you
talk to him yeah
and he he's writing a biography of the
stitcher and and he gave me that potato
I just want to read what his stitchers
daughter Betty said about Sinclair Lewis
right Betty later recalled the famous
house guest and and since our Lewis was
a house guest at stitchers home yeah he
was very considerate but not too
conscientious she writes he had the
florist deliver huge baskets of flowers
to his charming hostess my mother and
then charged them to dad he raved at our
Jessie's cooking and then Jesse would
forego the vacuuming to consort I'm
sorry to concoct some special
for supper and likely as not read that
was his nickname read Lewis would just
eat at the Athletic Club that night he
slept till noon used innumerable bath
towels wiped his razor blade on mothers
linen face towels refused to send his
shirts to the laundry because Jesse was
such a nice ironer brought a veritable
host of friends home late at night and
expected sustenance and gaiety why did
you put that in well that gave partly a
picture of this tumultuous time he spent
in Kansas City and he had stitcher
thought he was going to base the
character of Elmer Gantry or who was
then unnamed he went out there he's
going to write a novel about a preacher
so we went out to research it in Kansas
City and stitcher introduced him around
and and helped him but Louis thoughts
today was too mainstream and he needed
somebody who was more critical of the
church and he found another minister
named Leon Burkett so he still based
some of Elmer Gantry on stitcher
stitcher was known as big bill and he
was an ex-athlete and and you know sort
of a a strong manly kind of guy and and
he got some of Elmer Gantry stalk from
stitcher I think and but stitcher was
gonna disillusion because when he saw
the portrait of Elmer Gantry he had gone
around Kansas City saying Louis is gonna
use me in his novel and I think he
thought that it would be a novel like
Aerosmith about an idealistic young
minister who's and you know he said make
the Minister he would begin with his
flaws and everything but Louis was one
of them had a more radical criticism of
the church and so he he based the
character on a lot of Ministers actually
and according to mrs. Birkhead
well stitcher to continue with him he
was missed when the book came out and
later he preached his sermons saying
that Lewis had been drunk when he wrote
it all the time he was writing it which
was only partially true a very small
extent true but anyway in Lewis was
angered by that and and he accused and
then later stood you apologized and
Lewis said he would not accept the
apology because stitcher too already got
enough publicity out of him or something
like that a couple of little things he
was a janitor for Upton Sinclair yes
that's he dropped out of Yale in his
junior year was a friend a fellow poet
and radical named Updegraff and and
Sinclair with the the money had made
from the jungle he was a best seller and
he bought this estate along the Hudson
called Helicon Hall and he was going to
set up four co-operative Commonwealth
there he got a group of mostly literary
people and our academic people and they
would live there cooperatively and they
each one would do certain tasks and and
they had children their children would
be raised in a common nursery daycare
like a daycare center and so the women
who were writers could be who were moms
could be free to work and that so Lewis
and Updegraff went there and they
thought they would be writers but they
were assigned to be janitor they spent
most of their time being janitors and
trying to cope with this enormous
furnace for this mansion who was
Marcella powers
Porcello Powers was Louis's last love
she was when they met she was 18 and he
was 53 I believe she was an actress
aspiring actress and apprentice in the
summer stock company and as she cute he
bought his lines he had
into acting in the 30s and this was in
1939 and and he fell for her and and and
she became his girlfriend for how long
well it she it lasted through about 1947
and then she married she I I think she
was very fond of him but she she said I
love red but I'm not in love with him
and and she had a roving eye you might
say and and she started going out with
other guys I guess and finally he had to
make a compromise with her so that she
would give her freedom to see younger
man really and and in World War two she
was dating all that GIS and everything
and but he would constantly get her you
know try to get her to come out see he's
a living at mini up in Minnesota then
he's saying he got her pregnant and it
seemed to be he refers to this letter to
junior and her little junior which we
could have had but I can't find any
other confirmation of that but some
people thought there was no nothing
sexual about their interest but I think
there was you we don't have much time so
I'm jumping around that Ernest Hemingway
I had a character in one of his books
and I want to quote what the character
said and it was before I reaffirmed to
San Carlos yes they spy a man in the
restaurant with this is these are Ernest
Hemingway's words a strange face like an
over and large disappointed weasel or
ferret it looked as pockmarked and as
blemished to the mountains of the Moon
seen through a cheap telescope and the
colonel thought it looked like gurbles
face if hair gurbles had ever been in a
plane that burned and not been able to
bail out before the fire reached him a
little spit ran out of the
corner of his mouth as he spoke peering
Lee with the elderly wholesome looking
woman who was with him talking about
Sinclair Lewis yeah what was he a
strange-looking guy
very cool poetry yeah he had well you
know he was tall and he was red-haired
and but his complexion is he had skin
problems he had acne as a kid and then
treated with the x-rays and it may have
contributed but anyway he had a
hereditary disposition to skin cancer
and that broke out and in the 20s he
started having these basal cell skin
cancer eruptions on his face and he
would have to treat them and they left
seemed to leave scars and his face would
get all red and covered with scars and
HL Mencken his friends that had looked
like a lizard's skin sometimes and and
sometimes the treatments would clear it
up but it would come back and so it left
him as skin very rough and pockmarked
and and he was very self-conscious about
it it was very sad but he could never
quite get rid of it but he he would have
these treated periodically and Hemingway
had it formed a distinct dislike to him
and and got his revenge in this very
cruel way voted the most eccentric out
of his Yale class in 1907 he saves the
loneliest man in the world yeah that's
what people said yeah who knew him they
felt that would you have liked him you
think I think he could be very charming
and and entertaining and and interesting
you know he he would he was good on
politics when he's married to Dorothy
she was you know the real policy wonk
and the columnist and but he would sit
around making common sense shrewd
observations on politics and and I think
he could be very funny on politics and
and that was the problem with their
marriage was that she was always
more innocent politics and he was in a
way I mean she was always talking about
the situation what's the situation in
Europe the situation in Washington and
he said I'm sick of hearing about the
situation and she monopolized the
compass conversation and and she was
crusading against Hitler in the thirties
and he said if we ever divorced I'm
gonna name Hitler as a correspondent and
so he was and so she was invented a
character called the grouse and that she
used him in their column and that was
read Lewis what year did he die and he
died at 51 in Rome where is he buried
he's buried in Sauk center and in the
index to his mother and father have you
been there battling
oh yeah several times and you ever go
back to your hometown of Crawford's no I
do I haven't been there recently but I
haven't gone back for my high school
reunions and my parents were no longer
alive so I don't have as much reason to
go back to go back my mother was there
for a long time and and so I miss going
back there and in a way but I just
haven't had any particular cause -
what's your next book well I haven't
decided
ya know the subject but I hope some kind
of biography perhaps they take a long
time and I'm looking into my some
possibly German Americans something
about Germans Americans history their
history in this country and how long did
it take you to write this book well that
started in the nineteen ninety-three and
took about seven or eight years takes a
long time for these biographies when I
was working at the nation part-time
during this period
our guest is Richard Langman this is the
book called Sinclair Lewis a rebel from
Main Street thank you very much thank
you